in pakistan islamic state militants have
kidnapped and murdered 11
coal miners in balochistan province in
the country's southwest
all of the victims belong to the shia
hazara minority
their families have been staging a
sit-in for several days demanding strong
decisive action
the military has pledged to track down
the attackers but the hazara communities
say their pleas for protection
have long gone unanswered hundreds of
hazaras have been killed in attacks over
the last decade
joining us is dw shatsev jilani in
islamabad
zeb i understand the hazara protesters
have delayed
bearing the men killed how big a deal is
that
well you know in the muslim tradition
this is the
ultimate form of expression of anger
these people have felt that they've been
targeted
for many years uh hundreds of their
community members have been killed in
targeted
shooting in quetta in balochistan
and they are now saying that we want the
prime minister to come here to assure us
that the culprits will be caught and
then there will be
an end to the targeting of hazara
muslims in balochistan so they are still
there i just spoke to
our dw reporter in quetta and he's
saying there are very angry scenes there
are very emotional scenes because this
community feels
persecuted in pakistan now the hazaras
aren't the only group in balochistan who
feel like they
are being persecuted
tell us more about the political unrest
in the region
balochistan has been witnessing a
militant separatist
insurgency for well over 15
years now the ethnic baloch feel that
they are being exploited
they are being subjugated by the federal
government
in particular the pakistani army which
mainly comes from the biggest
populist province of punjab and
there's been you know long-running
animosity towards the federal government
the coach want more rights they want to
be
equal partners in the pakistani
federation
and some of them have taken to the
mountains the pakistani army
issued a statement yesterday saying the
terrorists will be caught they will be
punished uh
the army says that india is involved in
balochistan and in
encouraging this kind of insurgency well
if you can stay with us chat we have
more to talk about but first
here's a report on one of the many
thousands of people activists say
have gone missing in the region
hani baloch says they came for her just
weeks before her wedding
armed men from pakistan's security
services she claims
she says she and her fiance were accused
of being part of a baloch
terrorist organization and taken
to a secret jail
they gave us electric shocks while we
sat down on chairs
they hit my right foot with a rifle i'm
in pain when i walk
they hit my head with the rifle i had
six stitches on my head
the 27 year old denies any links to
anti-government groups
she was released after three months but
has heard nothing from her fiance
nasim activists claim thousands of
baloch people like nassim
have been disappeared over the years
resentment simmers in the region
poverty has sparked an insurgency
movement
residents say they don't get their fair
share of the region's gas and mineral
wealth
a landmark 2015 investment deal between
pakistan and china
has further escalated tensions
the cpec deal has ignited it because
balochistan is not receiving any share
even labor is being brought from punjab
or china
there's no trust in baloch workers
they are not being given work over there
so it's creating
more hatred
disappearances have increased in recent
years
but activists say not all of those
missing are insurgents
abdul hamid baloch says his brother was
taken away in july
last year his family are left asking
why
we fear that if they know that i'm
talking about what's happening in
balochistan
maybe they will pick me up and dump me
after killing me
if someone committed a crime they should
be punished but what is my mother's
crime
why is she being punished she has been
weeping for her son
day and night now she has stopped
speaking
hani doesn't understand the reasons for
the kidnappings either
she just waits hoping she'll one day be
able to be nasim's wife
that's quite an intense story there
shuts up the report
mentions chinese investment in the
region
can you go into that a bit more and why
that's an issue in all this
so you know we were talking earlier
about the baloch separatist
insurgency now china is investing
heavily in pakistan it is building roads
it is building a deep sea port uh in
gawadar
on the in balochistan and the baloch
nationalists feel
that this is a ploy by the pakistani
federal government by the army
to take away further resources from
balochistan
because they are saying we are not
benefiting from it whatever you are
doing to
provide one belt one road uh project
in pakistan balerch are not really
benefiting from it
so there's a lot of suspicion there's a
lot of animosity towards the
this project called china pakistan
economic corridor
uh and that's why a lot of chinese have
been
attacked by militants in the past there
was an attack on chinese consulate
and they are saying we will target these
these infrastructure projects being
built by china
shout out jalani thank you for joining
us